all month we are counting down to
Broadway's biggest night it's a 76
annual Tony Awards it airs on June 11th
right here by the way on good old CBS
Ben Platt made Broadway history when he
won the Tony I remember this for best
actor in the musical dear Evan Hansen he
was only 23 at the time the youngest
person ever to win that award solo you
go Ben Platt now he's back on Broadway
in the musical Revival of parade and
he's nominated or guess what another
Tony in the best actor category parade
tells a true life story of Leo Frank a
Jewish factory worker in Atlanta who was
accused of the murder of a 13 year old
girl in 1913. rampant anti-Semitism
leads to his conviction and imprisonment
in this promotional video Ben's
character Leo sings It's not this is not
over yet after the governor agrees to
reopen the case
[Music]
it means the journey ahead might get
shorter
I might reach the end of my rope but
suddenly loud as a mortar there is hope
[Music]
oh
my gosh Ben Platt we welcome you we're
so glad you're here we've all seen the
play and thank you all for coming I
really appreciate it yeah I know I was
there amazing row eight seat 101 did you
see me anyway I briefly peeped you but
Ben this is the thing I'm embarrassed to
say I knew nothing about this play I
know it's a Revival it's a great way to
come in well it's called parade and so
it's a musical so I'm I'm prepared for
some Yankee Doodle Dandy some very
patriotic things
and all of a sudden the play is what it
is and I couldn't believe what I was
watching I can't imagine what it's like
for you to have to bring up the emotion
that you have to bring up night after
night to tell the story you wanted to
play this character you knew this play
very well I did well you know it's sort
of two-fold uh I'm a musical theater
lover nerd whatever you want to call it
since I was very very very very little
and so this is a show that's been
beloved by the community for a long time
it wasn't originally on Broadway in 98
and
um you know had a lot of critical
Acclaim and won some Tonys but didn't
quite hit the way that I think the
computer Community wanted it to and so
the music especially in the score and
the story have been beloved for a long
time so it's a show I've always loved
and then on top of that you know as a
Jewish person it's a story that's very
important and difficult and so I think I
always knew that those two things would
be a great kind of combination in making
me an authentic Storyteller for this
particular role so it's always been on
my list of things I'd love to do and so
when Michael Arden our director reached
out to me and told me his concept for it
it was like a real number get it I get
it you assume anti-Semitism would be on
the decline all these years later 100
years nearly or more after uh Leo
Frank's death and yet it's not and to my
amazement in a preview of the show there
are actually Neo-Nazi sympathizers
protesting outside it sounds made up to
even say that it's really insane it's
not something we expected it was our
first performance and we were all doing
a circle on stage that's sort of like a
bonding circle before we went on and our
stage manager very commonly was like
just so you all know there are
protesters outside kind of you know
accosting some of the people who are
trying to get into the theater but
people are undeterred and they're
heading inside and they're excited to
see it and I think it was obviously
disappointing and scary but also really
galvanizing and reminded us all how
urgent this particular story is and
there's been lots of little things along
the way that have been sort of the
universe letting us all know that this
is really the story to be telling at
this current moment uh and I think so
that was painful to me to say one
certainly once I saw the play and then
to hear the backstory wasn't that
painful for you of course I mean it
makes it and you can't particularly when
you're doing a period piece or a Revival
you think okay I'm going to be able to
really remove myself from this and I'll
be I'll assume this character and live
in this world and then go home and none
of it will come with me yeah which you
know maybe naively I thought especially
after Evan Hansen which was such a bleed
of contemporary life and you know hard
to leave behind but this has been the
same in the sense that it's you know it
feels very frighteningly contemporary
the subject matter the storytelling and
uh it's it's tough to think that we
haven't come very far in those even more
important and more reason that that it
matters in this moment I would say
intermission normally people walk away
they're not thinking anything you are
there on stage in intermission what is
that moment like for you I sat there
just watching you the whole time what is
that moment you know it's again Michael
Arden our director is really brilliant
and when he first pitched me the show
that was among his initial Concepts was
this idea that Leah would stay on stage
you know he's imprisoned this this man
Leo Frank was in prison for the last two
years of his life and the show is very
propulsive and has to cover a lot of
ground and big ideas and Leo and Lucille
act as sort of symbols for a lot of
things and I think for me it's it's
brilliant on Michael's behalf because
it's a moment to really pay homage to
just this human being and this man who
was was in isolation for the end of his
life and really have a moment every
night where that's the only focus and I
think for the audience it really
challenges them in terms of am I willing
to entirely disengage or do I sort of
partially disengage and you know I
appreciate people that you know I think
there's all valid responses but I
certainly appreciate when people just
decide that they want to just take
something when's your intermission
there's an amazing number called
rumbling and rolling that opens up
and I am not in that so I can stick so
Ben let me ask you
um the moment that for me I think and
for the audience was incredibly moving
is right before you're about to be
lynched you recite a prayer the Shema
which uh is everybody just starts to
break down and as you do that you say
that this role has brought you closer to
your Jewish identity were you were you
apart from it before
you know I wouldn't say apart from it I
think you know as a Jew there's like all
this rhetoric about what makes a good
Jew what makes a bad Jew and you know
are you you know if you go to Temple
holiday exactly and as I've grown older
there's like certain observances and
theologies that just don't resonate with
me the same way and I think you know
sometimes you think does that make me
less connected to my Judaism but I think
in doing this show you know Lucille for
example the the the the the woman who is
married to to Leo has really assimilated
into the culture of the South and yet
this whole trial makes her have to
really undeniably accept her own Judaism
even though she's not nearly as
observant as her husband and I think
there's something so undeniable about
doing like a 23andMe and seeing that
your ethnic makeup is Ashkenazi Jew and
it's like regardless of whether I go to
Temple or not I'm you know I'm a Jew so
yeah I think it has allowed me to just
accept that and really Embrace whatever
my cultural and you know emotional
version of Judaism might be and
certainly that moment of saying the
Shema you know it's hard to imagine as
an actor what that moment might be like
when you're about your life is about to
end and you can see it in front of you
and I can only imagine that you might go
to the kind of the recesses of your mind
into the most instinctual place and like
the thing that you can kind of fall back
on when all else fails and certainly as
a Jew I can relate to that being the
Shema because it's a prayer I said
before bed and you know we said it in
day school and camp and my kids say it
now before bed yes Ben congratulations
congratulations
go see this play yes rival of parade
currently at the Bernard B Jacobs
theater on Broadway